oh the saints are 10-1 the cowboys are
six and five and a few weeks ago chris
sims this looked like it could be a real
stinker because the cowboys were
unraveling three wins in a row later and
this to me is the ultimate clash of old
school football new school football the
innovative saints coming up with plays
on the fly the cowboys meat and potatoes
you know what you're going to get the
question is can you stop it and they get
together tonight and we'll find out
which style is going to be successful
yeah you're right it's a lot of strength
versus strength there's some weakness
versus weakness in the match-up i think
you know to to your point about you know
the new school old school that's what i
love about the new orleans saints they
have all the new school stuff you're
talking about the taste some hills the
speed sweeps trick plays different
formations but yet if they want to play
old school with that offensive line they
have and those two running backs like we
saw a few weeks ago when they went up to
baltimore and just ran the ball and
controlled the clock they can do that
too that's why the saints are the best
team in the nfl right now and yeah this
has the makings of a
special thursday match up i mean this
could be a playoff matchup here in the
future we have two teams on a thursday
who have actually a full week to prepare
which you know i like that because sean
payton as smart as he is you give him
three or four days it's hard for him to
come up with as many creative things as
he can come up with when you give him a
full week so we're gonna see both teams
at their best tonight too that's what
i'm excited about with this thursday
night matchup and of course uh
dallas is pretty desperate and they're
of course fighting for their nfc east
title
yeah that's a good point chris this is
the one thursday night every year where
the teams get a full week because
starting a few years ago once they went
full season or maybe the year after that
the nfl's began taking two of the six
teams that play on thanksgiving and
putting them against each other one week
later so they get the full week to
prepare for the game and the saints are
just operating on a higher level than
any other team there's seven and a half
point favorites on the road at dallas
and and they've blown out teams they i
feel like after beating the rams they
reached a higher level and the question
is can they carry that through the end
of the regular season and into the
postseason because it really is
impressive 51-14 win over the bengals in
cincinnati 48-7 or the defending super
bowl champions at home the following
sunday and the 31-17 win over atlanta
last thursday night was not as close as
31-17 would suggest it felt like the
saints smothered the falcons all game
long and now this is i mean if the
saints go into dallas and just mop up
the floor with the cowboys and and i
remember there was a game for the 85
bears where they went down to dallas and
won like 44-0 and it was like a stunner
like oh my god i can't believe that
happened like if it's an outcome like
that then i think it just underscores
the fact this is a special special
season for the saints and
they're the presumed super bowl team out
of the nfc and the presumed super bowl
champion but i'm not saying they're
going to do it but we have to keep our
eyes open for anything tonight and there
is a possibility the saints are just
going to walk onto that field and
completely outclass the cowboys well
they've answered so many questions for
us all year long right i mean whether
it's just toughness winning outside in
baltimore or new york oh can they handle
that stretch of you know ravings vikings
rams at one point during the year oh
okay answered that bell you know this x
super bowl chance eagles come into town
are they ready for that matchup oh they
blow them out you know out of the water
they've answered every question we've
had all year about this football team
that's why they're special
this is a different animal in dallas
dallas has
i would say the best defense to match up
with this new orleans offense that we've
seen new orleans play all year the first
reason being they have two corners on
the outside that in dallas that are of
course very talented the byron jones kid
number 31 he's the one that's really uh
the one that stands out he can match up
with the michael thomas and live on an
island there and i think dallas can feel
comfortable with that matchup of course
he's gonna lose a few of those but they
can at least go hey you can hold your
own in some big situations and we could
take that chance there
dallas's front is extremely good so they
can rush the passer they can stop the
run so this might be a defense uh at
least that i'm intrigued to see that can
slow down or match with some of the
weapons the saints have camara out of
the backfield in the pass game well they
got van der esch and jalen smith two
very athletic linebackers to cover so on
paper it does look like dallas's d
should be able to hang with new orleans
offense
will it be enough though yes
when you consider what the dallas
offense can or can't do that's the other
side of the equation hey we we held the
saints to 28 points the only problem is
we were only able to score 13. i mean
can that dallas offense we've seen
ezekiel with 86 touches over the last
three games in a 12-day span i think he
is putting himself into the fringes of
the mvp discussion this is a great
opportunity for him tonight to really i
mean we talked about todd gurley and
patrick mahomes a week and a half ago he
got drew brees and ezekiel elliott
tonight if elliott goes out there and
has another 200 total yard night
performance and the cowboys win all of a
sudden we're going to be saying hey
ezekiel elliott has something to say
about this mvp race but he's taken the
team on its back can you just i mean are
they good enough physically to impose
their will right you basically come out
and say this is what we're going to do
ezekiel is going to run the ball 25
times go ahead and try to stop him and
teams can't can the saints stop him yeah
that's i mean your spot that's the
question of the game right i mean can
the saints stop the physical run game of
the dallas cowboys i'm going to say yes
they got enough depth and big guys on
their defensive line run stopping
linebackers guys like demario davis
where i say yes right so i go that's
good i think the big thing is from that
to
further your point because you're right
i mean slowing down the saints offense
is like oh you held them to 24. that's a
good day you know can dallas make enough
plays in the pass game because there's
weakness on weakness really i mean if
there's the weakness to the new orleans
saints it's still that secondary yeah
it's stopped some of the bleeding here
as of late but dallas has found its
stride in the past game with amari
cooper a little bit you know new orleans
will take some chances and play
man-to-man and let him march on
lattimore or eli apple on an island
against amari cooper we've seen amari
cooper what he can do in one-on-one
coverage on thanksgiving he's really
found his stride once again back in
dallas and is playing awesome football
so that going back to the point is
really the million dollar question of
the game for me can dallas's pass
offense just do enough to get first
downs and keep them on the field and
make a few plays here and there to where
new orleans can back away from the line
of scrimmage a little bit and then they
can still kind of pound the rock in the
run game that's where i see it
but i mean that that's the key the
dallas pass game is fueled by the
ability to run and when you look what
the saints have done this year they're
giving up 3.6 yards per attempt that's
tied with the bears for the best in the
nfl and they allow a total the saints do
of 73.2 yards on the ground per game it
really it you know we've been saying
this for a few weeks now you get a
feeling in the first five to 10 minutes
of a cowboys game whether or not they're
going to have a chance whether or not
their style is going to work and uh you
know we'll see they were back and forth
with washington last week until they
pulled away in the second half and i
think the longer the cowboys can keep
this close
they're going to have a chance that
maybe they get a few lucky plays in the
second half they wear them down
physically in the second half and pull
away and i think for the saints the flip
side is come out and try to deliver an
early knockout make the game boring get
up by 20 or more because if you're up by
20 or more the cowboys do not have the
juice to close that gap and and if
you're the saints i think you want to
take the crowd out of it you want to
take the cowboys out of it you want to
pop that bubble early because i think if
the cowboys are behind really by more
than two scores i think it's over yeah i
i would agree i think it would be hard
for them to get in a shootout or any
type of game that way where i'd go oh i
feel comfortable that you know dak
prescott and that pass offense is gonna
match you know touchdown for touchdown
and drive for drive with drew brees and
company no i don't see that happening um
you know i i guess the big thing is for
for dallas overall
their their offense yes it's limited
it's about one-on-one plays well they
come up with a few creative wrinkles for
dak prescott to run the ball that way uh
that's what i'm going to be interested
to see too because i just think some of
the status quo run plays too with the
depth and how well the front seven is
coach for the new orleans saints so
you're not just going to be able to
smash it straight forward you know you
talked about like the emotion of the
game there and new orleans wanting to
get up uh and of course i mean you're
right about that i'll say this dallas is
an emotion team and we've already heard
this week right that jerry jones wants
his team to play like a super bowl champ
that that's really one of the keys i
look at for the game too can new orleans
weather the early storm of emotion from
the dallas cowboys right we've seen
dallas on monday night a few weeks ago
against the tennessee titans where they
ended up only being up three nothing but
if you remember they what missed a chip
shot field goal dak press got through an
interception they came out and really
overwhelmed tennessee at first and we
all went wow they should be up 17 to
nothing and they're not and they ended
up losing but that is the type of team
they are they're going to be
foaming at the mouth tonight they know
this is a big test for them they know
who's coming into town they got to win
the nfcs their owner's on their butt
their coach is kind of on the hot seat
and they're going to want to show that
they're a super bowl caliber team and
can new orleans stop that initial wave
of motion and still be even in the game
if they are they're going to win but if
they're down 10 nothing early then i go
ooh this might be close throughout
i go back to that that eagles game where
we thought i thought you thought the
eagles were going to overpower the
cowboys in prime time and maybe to the
point where jason garrett would get
fired the next day that was the first
game where ezekiel elliott really did
get through to his teammates these are
must-win scenarios and they've done it
for three straight weeks and elliot has
showed the kind of leadership that a
team that has underachieved needs in
order to get the best possible
performance and and this is the ultimate
test so far now it doesn't win anything
for the cowboys they still have to fight
to get to the postseason but this is the
validation of everything they've done
the last three weeks if they can go
toe-to-toe with the saints and if they
can find a way to outscore the saints
then they really can view themselves as
a team that can contend in the nfc that
maybe could go to la and give the rams
all they could handle they can play
january football at a time when we see
these high-powered offenses that may or
may not translate to single elimination
settings because you get knocked wobbly
a little bit and all of a sudden you
can't you can't do what you've done and
that physical team knocks you in the
mouth a few times and it's game over so
this would be a great
litanist test yes
very well said good use of that word
there
it it really is that's exactly what it
is though for the dallas cowboys and i
think you know you talked about just the
start of that domination with the
philadelphia eagles game and the run
game you know again i know you've heard
me say this probably five times over the
last three weeks but i still will give
credit to mark columbo their new
offensive line coach i do think that
he's added a little bit more creativity
to the run game and he seems to find
at least from my film study like one or
two formations or offensive run plays a
week that kind of expose a run secondary
a little bit you know the eagles game it
was oh cutback lanes where the corner
had to be responsible for the c or d gap
and the run game and he made sure they
came back to there and got okay you want
to make your corner in charge of that
gap
let's have him tackle ezekiel elliott
and see how it goes and then ezekiel
would run by him for 15 or 20 yards he's
done very good job in that and finding
just little holes in team schemes as far
as what's wrong in their run defense and
i think that's why we've seen a little
more success from
that department with dallas lately
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports